who was responsible for the death of the
Lord Jesus Christ
okay let's go into some meat are you
ready God the
father Jesus
himself the Jews not all not
generalizing the Romans but not even all
the Romans should we now condemn all the
Italians and with that said all human
creatures okay let me repeat it again
when I say Jews not every Jew just like
when I say the Romans not every every
Roman killed Jesus or the Roman
soldiers understand so when you you say
Jews you don't mean every single Jew
just like when you say Romans you don't
mean every single Roman I'm being
politic correct I'm being biblically
correct so God the
father was responsible for death of
Christ Jesus was responsible for his own
death because he said no one can take my
life away from me I'm going to prove
from scripture Jews Romans and every
every human
sinner all of these groups are involved
okay now let's go in scripture and prove
it are we
ready are we ready now to quote
scripture to prove
it and I'm going to come back to that
Matthew 27 part where does it say God
the father was responsible for the death
of Christ Isaiah
53:6 are you ready to learn now class
has
begun Isaiah 53:6 here you go first
verse all we like sheep have gone astray
we have turned everyone to his own way
and the Lord
yahwah here the Father Here Jehovah's
the father has laid on him the iniquity
of us all Isaiah
53:6
now Isaiah 53:
10 Isaiah
53:1 okay get
ready father son Lord Jesus Christ Holy
Spirit be glorified save me from error
and from being politically correct and
not to be a crowd pleaser Isaiah 53:10
and bring them in JS For Your Glory not
for my praise yet it pleased the Lord to
bruise him yahwah this is his father
other translations are even more
forceful to crush him who crushed him
the
father who laid on him the iniquity of
us all the
father you with me there
you caught
it so the Lord laid iniquity on him and
crushed him bruised him he has put him
to grief who put him to grief the
father who grieved him the father who
bruised crushed him the father who laid
the sins on him the father when you make
his soul an offering for
sin he shall see his seed he shall
prolong his day in the pleasure of the
Lord yahwah Jehovah shall prosper in his
hand so the father Jesus why do I say
Jesus because in John
101718 John
101718 here you
go Jesus says
this therefore my father loves me
because I lay down my
life that I may take it again
therefore my father loves me because I
lay down my life that I may take it
again no one takes it from
me no one takes it from me nobody can
kill me nobody can make me die but I lay
it down of myself I have power to lay it
down and I have power to take it
again this command I received from my
father see it so the father crushed him
grieved him and laid the sins of the
world upon him the son says the reason
why the father did it because I agreed
and accepted my faith I of my own
accord accepted the father's will for me
to die for Sinners because if I didn't
want to die I Wouldn't Die no one can
take my life away from me we got
that is that clear so far
before I move on I can't move on if you
don't get
it
okay and now the Jews and the Romans the
Jews and the Romans now remember just
like not every Roman killed Jesus not
every
Jew and Jesus said I don't want to die
don't can take it away and he also tells
Peter who tried to stop the Jews who
tried to stop the Jews
from arresting him now again notice I
said Jews because now you get it the
Jews doesn't mean every single
Jew doesn't mean every single Jew now
watch what he says in Matthew 26
50-54 Matthew 2650 to 54 watch here look
what the L Lord Jesus
says when they came toist and Peter
tried to stop the Jews by cutting the
ear of the high priest's servant the
high priest servant named MOS now how do
we know it's Peter and how do we know
the high priest's servant his name is
malus because John 18 tells us now watch
here Focus Andre Adrian Matthew 2650 to
54 but Jesus said to him friend why have
you come then they came and laid hands
on Jesus and took him and suddenly one
of those who were with Jesus stretched
out his hand and Drew his sword John 18
tells us that was Peter and he cut off
malus gives us the name malos who was a
servant high priest struck the servant
high priest and cut off his here but
Jesus said to him put your sword in its
place for all who take the sword will
perish By The Sword now notice what I
Lord said or do you think that I cannot
now pray to my father and he'll provide
me with more than 12 Legions of angels
how then could the scriptures be
fulfilled that it must happen thus do
you see what he says I don't need you to
protect me no one can take my life I
choose to die and then I will raise
myself up on the third day in point of
fact I can now dispatch 12 Legion of
angels and wipe out everything in front
of me if I don't want to
die got
it okay we got that so
far are you learning what the Bible says
who's
responsible in in short everyone's
responsible father son those Jews Romans
but then because we all Sinners and
Jesus chose to die we all responsible
because Jesus and his love Came To Die
for our sins so in reality all of us are
responsible okay but hold on and I'm
going to show you that even the Jews in
the to said they killed Jesus even the
Jews in the
Tet right now watch
here yes the Jews were responsible not
all Jews not every Jew and yes the
Romans were responsible not all Romans
not every Roman Roman acts 222- 24 Peter
filled with the Holy Spirit what does he
say acts 222- 24 men of Israel hear
these words Jesus of Nazareth a man
attested by God to you by Miracles
wonders and signs which God did through
him in your midst as you yourselves also
know him being delivered by the
determined purpose and for knowledge of
God
you you have taken son of the Jews by
Lawless hands so you've handed them over
to Lawless hands meaning Gentiles who
have no regard for the law have
crucified and put to death whom God
raised up having Loos the Pains of death
because it was
impossible it was not possible it was
impossible that he should be that he
should be held by
it
okay acts 222- 24 yeah you Jews hand
them were to the
Romans Lawless men meaning they had no
regard for the law and they killed him
but it was impossible for him to stay
dead because he's life and life swallows
up
death okay acts
236 all the way to 41 acts 236 to 41
watch
here okay get ready so far you're
learning the Bible teaches I hope you're
enjoying this you're learning you're
growing by the power of the Holy Spirit
using me to teach you
you acts 236 to
41 therefore let all the house of Israel
know assuredly that God has made this
Jesus whom you
crucified you crucified so you Jews
crucified but wait earlier he said you
hand him over to Lawless men and they
crucified him both the Lord and Christ
he made him both Lord and Christ now
when they heard this they were cut to
the heart they were cut to the heart and
said to Peter and the rest of the
Apostles men and Brethren what shall we
do then Peter said to them repent and
let every one of you be baptized in the
name of Jesus Christ for the remission
of sins right and you shall receive the
gift of the holy spirit for the promise
is to you and to your children and to
all who are far off as many as the Lord
Our God will call now pay attention to
verse 39 for the promises to you and to
your children and to all who are far off
as many as the Lord Our God will call
because I'm going to come back to
this and with many other words he
testified and exhorted them saying be
saved from this perverse generation then
those who gladly received his word were
baptized and that day about 3,000 Souls
were added to them okay now watch
here watch what's going to happen here
acts
three acts three sorry about
that 13 to 26 Acts 3
13 to 26 watch here let's get them ready
watch
here the long one I'm G to break it down
into two first of
all watch here okay guys you got to
follow with me acts 3:13 to
yeah the god of Abraham acts 3:13 to 26
we're going to read we're going to break
it down acts 3:1 13- 16 first the god of
Abraham Isaac and Jacob the god of our
fathers glorified a servant Jesus whom
you he's talking to the Jews deliver up
and denied in the presence of pilate now
notice you Jews gave him to
pilate when he was determined let him go
but you denied the Holy One and the just
and asked for murder to be granted to
you that's when they said give us
Barabas obviously not all the Jews were
there not all the Jews said give us
vabis right so let's understand the
statements contextually historically not
all the Jews were there saying release
barabus kill Jesus right okay keep that
in mind and ask for a murderer to be
Grant to you and killed the Prince of
Life the ruler of life now notice how
the biblical language Works they didn't
actually kill him pilate did and pilate
didn't actually kill him the Roman
soldiers did you see how the Bible works
even in the Bible God takes
responsibility for actions committed by
others do you remember Isaiah 53 God
crushed him and caused him grief laid
the sins upon of us on him well God
didn't nail him to the Cross meaning the
Father the father didn't whip him the
father didn't beat him the father didn't
put a crown of thorns on his head the
father didn't nail him to the Cross
right so notice how biblical language
Works God takes responsibility for the
actions of others now why does he take
responsibility so that what you do can
be said that God is doing because if God
doesn't permit you you can't do
anything so God will often take
responsibility for your
actions and describe your actions as his
actions as he's the one doing it because
in the Bible you cannot do anything
unless God permits it similarly here it
says to the Jews you killed them but
Peter just said it wasn't was pilot why
because Peter is saying it is your
actions that resulted in the Romans
Killing Jesus so you are
complicit likewise it was pilate's
action and handing him over to the
Romans to kill him right so he's
complicit you see how the biblical
language works are we
understanding are you see how it's
working whom God God raised from the
dead of which we Are Witnesses and his
name through faith in his name has made
this man strong whom you see and know
yes the faith which comes through him
has given him this Prof perfect
soundness in the presence of you all
okay are you seeing how the Bible works
are you learning biblical language God
crushed him grieved him no he didn't the
Jews did no they didn't pilate did no he
didn't the Romans
did in other words you share respons
ility in the actions of others if you
are the cause or the
reason these things are taking place so
God is the reason why Christ died
because if God didn't want Christ to die
for our sins no one could lay a finger
on Christ so that's number one it was
the Jews who then handed him over to be
killed by the Romans so they're
complicit so you see how it works
because the Romans killed
Jesus due to the orders of pilate pilot
is now complicit so you can say pilate
killed them but because the Jews handed
Jesus over to pilate and demanded that
pilate kill him you can say the Jews
killed him because they're
complicit but because it was God's will
for Jesus to die and allowed the Jews to
hand Jesus over to pilate who handed
over to the Romans you could say God the
Father crushed
Jesus are we learning how the Bible
Works before I move
on but now watch this
though okay watch the rest of
it okay watch here acts 3:17 to 23
everyone learning acts 3:17 to
23 but watch what Peter says though
after saying you killed them by handing
over to Pilot to hand them to the Romans
yet now Brethren I know that you did it
in ignorance
as it also your rulers now here's what's
amazing about that statement how can
they be
ignorant yes sure sure yeah why don't
you I block your book when they saw
signs
wonders
Miracles that Jesus did especially the
rulers well in one sense they are
ignorant in that
they were not convinced that Jesus
fulfilled the prophecies nor were they
so familiar and acquainted with the Old
Testament to see how Jesus fulfilled the
prophecies you see the
point you with me
there so in one sense
though they shouldn't have been ingrant
because they knew the Old Testament but
at the same time though they had the Old
Testament they were still ignorant of
how the
Messiah would arrive and what he do and
this is proven by the historical
evidence showing that different Jews had
different understandings of Old
Testament prophecies concerning the
Messiah till this
day so this is why Peter is saying
you're ignorant in that though you have
the prophets and he's going to mention
it though you have the Old Testament
prophetic
witness due to your
unfamiliarity familiarity with the Old
Testament or your inability to
synthesize the Old Testament and see how
that all fits in in order to get an
accurate understanding of what the
Messiah would be who he'd be and what
he'd
do God is extending Mercy to you you
with me
there you understand how it works
because look what he says yet now
Brethren I know that you did it in
ignorance and it also your rulers but
those things which God foretold by The
Moth of All His prophets that the Christ
would suffer he has fulfilled repent
then therefore and be converted that
your sins may be blotted out so that
times of refreshing may come from the
presence of the Lord and that he may
send Jesus Christ who has preached to
you before whom Heaven Must receive he
he remains in heaven heaven receives him
and he won't leave heaven and return
until the times of restoration of all
things which God has spoken by the mouth
of all his holy prophets since the world
began for Moses truly
said to the fathers the Lord your God
will raise up for you a prophet like me
from your brethren him you shall hear in
all things whatever he says to you and
it shall be it shall be that every soul
who will not hear that Prophet shall be
utterly
destroyed from among the people okay Now
watch how he concludes it watch here
Acts 3 24-26 so I just quoted acts 31
13- 26 but I had to break it down acts
32 24-26 if you're paying attention and
ask the Holy Spirit to help you and to
help me to help you you're going to
learn watch
here yes and all the prophets from
Samuel and those who follow as many as
have spoken have also foretold these
days all the prophets foretold these
events
you are the sons of the prophets and the
Covenant which God made with our fathers
saying to Abraham and in your seed all
the families of the Earth shall be
blessed now watch are they cursed to you
first God having raised up his servant
Jesus sent him to curse you to bless you
in turning away every one of you from
your iniquities so how can a Christian
who loves the Bible of Jesus accuse Jews
of deide and persecute them marginalize
them and get them murdered what are you
talking
about what are you talking
about here it is acts 3:26
again what Bible are you reading
man and I'm not being politically
correct I'm being honest to scripture
may the Lord Purge my motives here it is
acts 3:26 to you first God having raised
up his servant Jesus sent to to bless
you but the way they would read it sent
him to curse you to condemn you to damn
you to get people to accuse you of being
God murderers deide murdering God and
then persecute you and marginalize you
is that what it
says is that what it
says God raised up Jesus from the dead
and exalted him to reign as Lord over
Heaven and Earth and he sent him
through
our
preaching we are his agents through our
through our agency to Proclaim to you he
desires to bless you and love you and
forgive you and restore you to give all
of Israel repentance enable them to
repent by the spirit sent to them to
convict them repent but what do you do
from that moment on is between you and
the spirit because you can resist or
submit because he wants to give Israel
forgiveness of sins so what is acts
31326 saying though you handed him over
to be
killed you did it in ignorance now let
me break that down so you can understand
well how can they be ignorant how could
the rulers be ignorant he said the
rulers and you were ignorant didn't
Jesus do Miracle after Miracle to
confirm who he is yeah but even
Deuteronomy 13 1-10 says false prophets
and dreamers and dreams will do miracles
but then preach Gods you have not known
so don't follow them just because they
do
Miracles because they have to be
consistent with the already established
Old Testament yeah but didn't he point
to prophecies that Messiah would suffer
die and rise again yes but here's the
problem just because you have the Old
Testament just because someone quotes
the verse that doesn't mean you still
are
able to understand
what you're reading and being told
especially when you have
tradition
tradition that hinders you from seeing
the clear teaching of
scripture and the fact that the Jews
were ignorant about the
Messiah is easily proven when you look
at the historical context and note
different Jews had different views of
and time can I give you a little history
so by ignorance what he means is not
that you don't know the Old Testament
you have it but just because you haven't
and read it doesn't mean you've
understood it it is due to your lack of
understanding of the Old Testament and
the nature of the Messiah either because
you haven't read it carefully or because
the Traditions you've inherited have
hindered you from seeing the clear
teaching that's why you're ignorant and
the same phenomenon exists today among
the Jews and Christians how many
Christians are ignorant of how Christ
will return physically bodily to the
Earth how many different Christian views
we have regarding the return of Christ
Our Lord among
Christians forget the Jews today and how
they view the Old
Testament how many Christians who have
the New Testament still can't agree on
how Christ will return
exactly is there a 70-year church
ulation or is it 3 and a half years will
there be a Rapture of the church before
the seven years or in the midpoint or at
the end or is there no Rapture at all
will there be a thousand year of Christ
or is that spiritual symbolic and
already took place when Christ went to
heaven so aren't we
ignorant yeah but don't we have the the
Bible yes but we're still ignorant
that's what Peter is saying ignorance
doesn't mean
you don't know what the Bible says and
you're not reading it no ignorance means
you know what the Bible is
saying right God will raise up a prophet
like Moses okay you know that you see
that but have you understood that
saying you see the
difference although you know what it
says but you still don't understand what
it says either because you're reading it
on a surface level or because because
you have Traditions imposed on you that
affects the way you see the
text so this is why the Jews were
scandalized by Jesus because here's a
Jew claiming to be God In the Flesh and
the Messiah who would die and rise again
and they're being blown away wait number
one we haven't been told the Messiah
will die and rise again let alone that
Messiah will be God what are you talking
about you see the point
you're already shocking Us by telling us
Messiah would be killed for our sins and
be raised and exalted and then return
again physically to establish God's
Kingdom on
Earth and then to top it off you're not
claiming to be God so you're blowing our
world view out of the
waters you're not only claiming to be
Messiah you're claiming to be the
Messiah who be killed for our sins and
then be raised and then go to heaven and
then return again and only at the second
coming when you return you're going to
establish God's Kingdom on
Earth and then to blow our minds even
further you're saying that Messiah is
God In the Flesh what do you you see the
point you see the pro the problem so
that's why Peter's saying Brethren you
did it in ignorance so God has mercy on
you and God doesn't want to condemn you
and curse you He sent Jesus to bless you
forgive you restore you enable to repent
cuz he loves you does that sound like
the Bible saying all the Jews are guilty
of DSi so let's go persecute
them no right okay but the Bible does
say Jews and it doesn't mean no see
sometimes General statements doesn't
mean everyone
specifically the rulers and those who
are there instigated by the rulers to
believe Jesus is the false Messiah
because who's preaching to the Jews and
saying you kill them
Peter Paul John James did they kill
Jesus no Peter tried to stop Jesus from
being killed hello Nicodemus was against
Jesus being killed hello Joseph ARA
member of San hedin was a secret follow
of Jesus and buried him his tomb hello
is it all making sense now